Speaker 1: Why did you actually choose plant pathology?
Speaker 2: Yeah, that's a good question.
There are many different areas I could have picked,
but I had a very good professor who taught us how actually plants get sick like humans, like animals,
plants also get a lot of diseases. Bacterial diseases, viral diseases, fungal diseases, a myriad of diseases.
And if they get sick then we have no food, so that was really in a simplified way, that was the reason.
And I found it very interesting also, the science of plant pathology, which is diseases of plants.
Speaker 1: You went to South America. What did you do in South America?
Speaker 2: So, I studied my undergraduate degree in Ethiopia and I got scholarship went to United States.
That's what I really wanted to do and so I studied there and I had I did my masters degree
and my PhD degree in America and I had, also after my PhD, I had a job as a scientist in the USA, in Cornell University.
So after that I was recruited by an international Agricultural Research Center based in Colombia.
So I had never been in Colombia before. They approached me to consider a job there.
So I was employed by the organization as a senior scientist and I moved there in Colombia. Yeah.
Speaker 1: What did you do in Colombia?
Speaker 2: In Colombia so I was a senior scientist in charge of diseases of forage plants.
And it is a very enjoyable setting, enjoyable job.
Because everything we did was to solve a problem for society, particularly for developing countries.
And it is a great phase for me and I get to learn a new language in Spanish.
The people are nice and the country is beautiful, and I met my husband there also.
He was at the same time
when I was recruited from United States the same company recruited him also from the Netherlands from his country,
and we met one day apart, we arrived there one day apart, basically yeah.
So, and then our daughter was also born there, in Colombia, so and both of us agree
and was a scientist was in the organization also, so it was very good.
And we, I feel we made a lot of difference for people.
We were working for, basically the developing world in South America, in Asia,
in Africa just based in Columbia so it was a very good time.
Speaker 1: You also educated a lot of Chinese students.
Speaker 2: Yes.
Speaker 1: So you became a friend of China.
Speaker 2: Yes I did so I think one of the exciting things is that in that organization you are a scientist for any
developing countries that need your skills and technologies.
So you are not particularly working for just one country or the other.
So, many different students, graduate students, came to work with me. So among those was many Chinese.
So the Chinese were partially funded by their government. So they came to do their research in my laboratory.
So they are really hard-working people, and I spend considerable amount of time also training them.
So that was my one of the success stories and I had Columbian students, I had Brazilians, I had many different kinds.
Speaker 1: The Chinese, well, it wasn't unnoticed that you educated a lot of Chinese people.
You got a medal from the Chinese.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
Speaker 1: Why did you decide to go to Africa then?
Speaker 2: Yeah. So, that was a turning point for me.
So all those years, I was in Columbia for 15 years and so agree was a scientist in the organization.
I was promoted also in the organization. So for my career, it was great.
But at the back of my mind, I was also thinking, and really contemplating, also, what is actually my impact for Africa.
Coming from a poor village knowing how people live, struggle to make ends meet.
So I was always questioning also whether that Colombia needs me more than Africa needed me.
But I think the turning point came in September 2006 as the Chinese gave me their highest award,
what they call the Friendship Award, for the role I had played in their agricultural research and developments
Speaker 2: And the impact basically, through the graduate students I trained,
who had become very successful scientists back in China. So, at the ceremony, there was a big ceremony there.
And on the stage, when it was announced that at that time from Ethiopia and I made this contribution to China.
It was another proud moment for me. I was embarrassed.
I was from a poor country and I was getting a gold medal from the premier of China for impact made in China.
and I was cautioning on the [INAUDIBLE] Does actually China need me more than Africa?
So that was the stage actually on the stage right there I decided okay I'm going back to Africa. So yeah.
Speaker 1: You became finally in Africa.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
Speaker 1: And director of this insect institute. Why an insect institute?
Speaker 2: Yeah, so when I came back to Africa I was immediately the head of this institute.
So I was recruited by another international organization based here in Nairobi to establish agricultural power
technology center for Africa, funded by the Canadian government.
So, it was a tough a job, but after the task but it give me opportunity to do something from scratch for Africa.
So I did that for five and a half years to establish the center. It became a very successful center.
I did the lot of money.
And send, I save up the program And so on, so then I was approached by another organization,
if I could take the position of a Vice President for Programs.
So I accepted that, but it was not a research organization, so I wanted to go back into the research organization.
This opportunity came to head ICIPE, the International Center of Insect Physiology and Ecology.
So I accepted that and so it is a perfect place for me with perfect programs for Africa. So why insects?
So people often ask me, wow, the whole organization for just insects? And why insects? That's what people ask, yeah.
But, yeah, this is a unique organization.
I think, as far as I know, the only organization that deals 100% on insects,
because insects are extremely important in our lives.
They are by far the most diverse and the most abundant animals on earth. They play various roles in our lives.
If you take bees, they play a critical role in pollinating our crops.
So if bees have to disappear tomorrow, our food source would be in big, big trouble.
So they pollinate our crops, like bees.
Insects also play a critical role as food source, food for humans and feed for animals.
So about 2 billion people in Africa, Latin America, Asia, consume insects as a source of protein.
So I believe this is also actually a source that has to be mainstream all across, I think,
the globe as a good source of high quality protein. Also bees give us also a lot of things, food, feed.
I mean, insects and wax and a range of things.
Insects also, they have also ecologically also there are insects that control other harmful insects also.
Insects play role also in degrading waste, plant waste, animal waste, and so on.
So in fact, if we don't have insects, our world will be a lot of, really mess, with a lot of garbage.
A lot of waste that we put which is not being degraded by some microbes and insects.
But unfortunately, also that insects also are harmful to also humans, animals, to crops.
They transmit a lot of disease.
Small things like mosquitoes kill more people every day than global conflicts put together.
So it hurts me to think with all the technologies we have, humans going, mankind going to the moon, going to space,
and so on. We are unable to defeat a tiny mosquito, to kill.
Every 80 seconds in Africa, children die from malaria, from a lot of mosquito transmitted diseases, dengue,
and yellow fever. And a lot of diseases come through that, transmitted through insects.
The same for animal diseases also. A wide range of animal diseases are transmitted through insects.
So climate change is an issue.
A recent report for example says, by the World Bank just came out, if we don't deal with climate change by 2030,
100 million more people will go into poverty.
So I think, I believe personally, that I think one of the biggest impacts of climate change is going to be insects,
also. As the world gets warmer, insects are going to shift also to warmer places.
A lot of African problems are going to be also problems somewhere else as it gets warm.
If we have to make the planet livable for us, in the many years ahead.
If we have to manage our food security, nutritional security.
If we have to develop the planet, we have to develop for the insects.
For the benefits and the harmful parts of what insects provide, yeah.
Speaker 1: Are people aware of somehow of this wide variety of properties that insects have?
Speaker 2: Mm, no, unfortunately not. I think we have to make people aware of that, I think we have to teach.
Speaker 1: Would you mind repeating my question? Sort of because otherwise you answer with yes or no.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
Speaker 1: So you think are people aware somehow of the wide variety of properties?
Speaker 2: No, I think people are not aware of all this variety of issues associated with insects.
So for example, if you take bees, almost everybody knows that honey comes from bees.
But a lot of people don't know that bees are critical for food securities, they pollinate crops.
Without bees and you don't have enough and some of the plants they require pollination by bees.
So, no, people don't know a lot about this.
And I think we have to teach it in school, in elementary school, in high school, in universities.
And I think in the general public, also to be aware of what insects do for people, yeah.
Speaker 1: Are there properties you think that are very beneficial from insects?
I mean, in terms of pharmaceutical properties, or anything they do well for us.
Speaker 2: Yeah, yeah insects play a lot of roles.
For example, there are insects that are uniquely found antibiotics, insects that uniquely produce
or have antibiotics for example.
Speaker 1: Should we do it again?
Speaker 2: Yeah, yeah.
Speaker 1: Can you mention some other, well, quite unique properties that we are not very aware of?
Speaker 2: Yeah, insects have a number of other uses as well. For example, the antibiotics for people, for animals.
I don't think we have investigated enough the unique antibiotics that exist in insects.
There are also other things that, for example, this insect called the soldier fly.
There are very good at processing a lot of waste, and converting them to fertilizer.
So yeah, there is a wide variety of use we can make out of insects.
Some of the airplane, helicopter design comes from insects, insect architecture, yeah. Yeah, so.
Speaker 1: What the uniqueness of your institute?
Speaker 2: Yeah, I think the uniqueness for me of this, of ICIPE, is one.
It is focused on really solving agricultural and housing constraints in Africa.
But what we produce is not just unique for Africa, it can be used globally.
It is also, we also focus on very environmentally-friendly and sustainable technologies and products.
We have, for example, over the years, generated biopesticides, pesticides that come naturally,
from a naturally existing fungus. And we manage,
Speaker 2: Insects, beneficial, not beneficial, harmful insects.
So these products now, are commercialized together with, in partnership with the private sector.
And so, it's registered now, they are registered in many countries in Africa.
And currently, they're being registered, so, in the European Union.
So what we produce, very environmentally-friendly, and not contaminating the environment.
Not harming other beneficial insects. So it's not only just useful for Africa.
But this can be used anywhere else, as well, in Europe, in North America.
So we are unique, in the sense that we focus on technologies and products that are environmentally-friendly.
And that are also sustainable for a long term or so. And that keeps a natural equilibrium also, yeah.
Speaker 1: How important is your institute for Africa, maybe for the world, and how would you describe it?
Speaker 2: I think it's very, very important.
I often ask my staff, that if we cease to exist tomorrow, would people line up asking for reopening of ICIPE?
And the answer is constantly yes. Because we are making a major impact, all across Africa.
And we are focused on major constraints. Constraints that are really an impediment for agricultural, and those issues.
So, is a very important organization for the continent, and globally as well, yeah.
Speaker 1: Why is it in Africa?
Speaker 2: Why is it in Africa, good question. It's based in Africa because it was founded by an African.
It was founded 45 years ago, in 1970, by a very renowned entomologist, insect scientist.
A professor, a Kenyan professor.
So it was founded as an international center, a small center within a university, and it expanded.
It expanded, and so today we have multiple nationalities of scientists and technical staff.
And reaching out across Africa and making impact.
And what I like about the organization is also that research, yeah, we do cutting-edge research.
We do, we make major breakthroughs, we publish in high quality journals internationally.
But all that, our work, is also is aimed to translate it to impact.
There's nothing we do, which is not short-term, or middle-term, or long-term, is not translated to impact.
And products that reach the end user, which is the farmers and the beneficiaries in Africa and beyond.
And so this really truly making science to work for people, for society.
Speaker 1: Can you describe how important insects are for the future of humanity?
Speaker 2: Yeah, excellent, very good question. Yeah, I think insects are really important for all our lives.
Bees, I think bees. Europe and North America already knows now, because the bee population is going declining.
Already knows that this is a problem, unless we solve this. Unless we take care of the house of the bees.
So that one, I think it goes without saying. That if bees, if they don't exist today, tomorrow, we're in trouble.
So that has to go on for the future.
I think for the future also, that if we have to diversify our food source, feed source.
And quality of protein, I think we have to mainstream the use of insects as food.
So there is, there are a variety, more than 2,000 species of insects are consumed globally.
And there are several of them in Africa. So people consume them, they go to the forest, they collect them seasonally.
Often it is women and children who are tasked, who are given this task. To go to the forest and collect the insects.
So sometimes when you collect them, so that you are going to, there is a tendency to over-harvest.
And then you can cause some of these insects trouble, their role in balancing the, the atmosphere, the equilibrium.
So, and, ICIPE has technology, the capability to mass-raise a lot of these species of insects.
And so, I think we have to change the perception of people, globally.
That insects, I mean, consuming insects, is not something out of the ordinary.
Two billion people have successfully been traditionally consuming them. We have to do the mainstream also.
So the conversion rate also, of feed, and insect protein, is a lot more efficient in insects.
So with a very limited amount of feed, substrate insects, you can get high-quality protein.
Compared to the same quality protein in beef, in cattle. So for climate change, also mitigation for, and so on.?
So I think insects are more What more compatible I think, yeah. More susceptible
Speaker 1: One of your research is actually published in article about locust.
You could better eat a locust that eat the food they eat.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
Speaker 1: Why? Can you explain that? What was, what did you?
Speaker 2: Yeah, so we have been working going them On a device insects also the protein
and nutritional profile of these insects also, the number of insects that are being consumed traditionally.
So we found that a lot of these insects actually have a higher or equivalent content of nutrition
and protein to equivalent to fish and to beef. So that is a good finding.
Locusts, so we published a recently about two months ago, a paper. Very exciting the finding.
So locusts are really big pests.
They go and they kind in they storm and they can completely wipe your crop in an overnight.
They consume a lot of granary crops or any vegetation.
But people also consumes them traditionally also in many parts of Africa and elsewhere.
But what we found is that locust is that in a laboratory setting, that are feed on wheat seedlings.
They convert the wheat seedlings may have very minute amount of steroids.
These are chemicals that are very useful to our health.
They reduce cholesterol, they do a lot of have a lot of benefit to health.
And so the locusts as it consume and then they have, we don't know the mechanisms there yet,
they have then capacity to convert this steroids 20 to 40 fold.
So if you have diet, locust based diet all across in your life incorporated into your diet,
that the chance of you having a cholesterol or a heart problem is much, much lower. So this is a an amazing finding.
So, I think if more and more if we find the beneficial effect of insects as food.
I think the perception of people will also change on incorporating insects into their diet sir.
Speaker 1: What will insect research do for the future of Africa?
Yeah, I think if we have effectively understand on, we are constantly understanding the insects, their physiologist,
their ecologist, their mechanism. How they transmit the diseases, how they're fascinating creatures sir?
Speaker 2: Creatures and if we understand that our better.
If we know, then we identify then several cycles in their life cycles severalspots where,
the weak spots where we can manage. So, I think we have to eradicate malaria.
So, why can't we with all this technology? Not just us, but the global scientific community.
Why can't we eradicate dengue?
Why can't we eradicate sees flies that are causing a lot of problem both in humans and in animals?
So, I think if we tackle all of these I think the future of Africa will be bright.
It will be less problem to deal with.
And so, a lot of the problems that you find in Africa, they're actually manageable, we can manage them,
we can tackle them.
So it's not so, yeah, we regularly make breakthroughs,
we recently that the a young group of scientist this is are CPA in my organization.
They discovered that certain mosquitoes, a certain population of the mosquitoes that transmit malaria.
And about a very small portion of them we don't know why they harbor bacteria in their body.
So those mosquitoes that harbor this bacteria, they are unable to transmit the malaria parasite.
So that is a major, major discovery. So what we have to what we are doing is that why?
What do this bacteria do to this insect making them resistant
and incapable of transmitting the malaria transmitting the malaria parasite??
And why only certain population, certain percentage of them, and the mosquito have it.
So if we knows that, and if we are able to transmit this bacteria to a wider range of the mosquito population.
It is possible to significantly reduce the malaria transmission.
So there is a lot of things we can do, and make a difference in Africa and elsewhere.
Speaker 1: People I talk to say you are in a hurry. What does that mean?
Speaker 2: [LAUGH] I'm in a hurry. I"m in hurry. I'm very impatient.
Yeah, because I think and I, if you talk to my staff also they'll tell you the same thing. I'm in a hurry.
I'm pushing constantly.
I'm impatient that is because I think we have to live our lives with a sense of urgency,
because every day we live that tomorrow, we are about to finish today.
Tomorrow we have one day less on our life, our lifetime. So, which means that we are not getting younger.
So we have to rush in to make sure that we have actually make a difference in people's lives, that we have lived, also,
our lives with a purpose. So, I think we shouldn't, I don't feel that I have to live for myself.
No, I shouldn't live for myself. I should feel a sense of responsibility for my other fellow human beings.
So that's why I'm in a hurry. I'm really in a hurry, yeah.
Speaker 1: What's the goal?
Speaker 2: I want to do something, I want to make a difference for people I want to,
Speaker 2: To solve a problems for people who are not able to solve it themselves. And I think we are fortunate.
As a scientist, I'm fortunate that I'm given this priceless knowledge and education.
So I have to use it, to, use it to publish a paper, but only to really use, to solve people's problems, yeah.
Speaker 1: What can science do for Africa, in this respect?
Speaker 2: Science can do a lot of things for Africa, and for the rest of the world,
I think We should be able to find solution for all our ailings.
We should be finding vaccine for malaria, we should be finding vaccine for HIV/AIDS. We should be defeating cancer.
So that's all possible I think. So science can do a lot of different things too for people and for the planet, yeah.
Speaker 1: What can Africa do for science.
Speaker 2: Africa can do a lot of things for science.
I think that's an excellent question that no one has ever asked me. I think governments have to value the science.
Technology is really important for the continent development for the people.
So they have to value that, they have to invest significant proportion of their resources to science and technology
and to other areas.
Because I think the difference between my country and your country, which is my husband's country,
is not a difference in our color, is not a difference in the location where we are, is a difference of capability
and education.
That investment, and the capability capacity of people to innovate, capacity of people to absorb new technologies,
and to invent a lot of different things.
If we don't do that, if Africa doesn't do that, it's never going to solve a lot of our problems.
So how is that the Netherlands which has miserable weather and can produce a lot of food not only for their people
but I think can produce a lot.
And we have this beautiful weather, beautiful sunshine, and a lot of resources, water and everything else
and we are not feeding ourselves. So it is again a capability issue for me, yeah.
And knowledge and technology and I think Africa has to do that to enhance it's ability to do.
Speaker 1: What can your institute do for Africa?
Speaker 2: It simply does a lot of things for Africa.
So we, environment work, as I have just said, we believe capacity is very critical.
Capacity, at the end of the day, capacity is development. Development is all about capacity of people.
So we have a very large capacity building unit. So every year, we see 100 to 150 graduate students all across Africa.
They do their masters degree, their PhD degree and, so and then we train them..
They are registered in many different universities but they do the research at this, [INAUDIBLE]
And so we are enhancing the scientific capability of many African countries in insect science.
But also we train also a lot of farmers in different things.
We train in the technologies that they adapt from us and so on.
So like this year, from January until October, ten months, is that? Is that ten months, yeah.
Ten months that we trained more than 10,000 people in various different technologies.
So this is begun, and we are a reluctantly small organization, okay? So I think this is a big contribution.
So we also yeah our products go all across Africa, technologies they go.
So one of the things which is difficult for us is to scale out the technologies to reach as many people as we can.
So for example we have the technologies we are going to visit tomorrow in the field.
Is absolutely fabulous technology, invented, created by and developed by superior and its partners.
But this is a technology that is really needed all across Africa.
But we are reaching only 10,000 to 20,000 farmers per year. But the technology is needed by millions of farmers.
So, now we are changing our model and partnering with governments and with individuals
and in the private sector to take the technology into accelerated and many different countries.
And so yeah, this was, yeah.
Speaker 1: You like to defend this case to many people, and share your thoughts with, wherever you can share,
because you also go to the President of your country, your
Speaker 2: Yeah, so it's very important for us to work with the governments
and to fit also with their own strategy plan also. So, we kinda just work in isolation.
So the Ethiopian government, for example, has a very clear strategy development plan.
So they took a number of our, products and technologies, and they fit them into their strategy.
So for one of our technologies, for example, they have a plan to reach minimum of 20,000 farmers with that technology,
a year. So they are going to expand it themselves, I think, once you give them.
And we do the technical backstopping, because it's a very knowledge intensive technology.
So you have to train farmers how to use it. But it's a fabulous technology.
And bee keeping also, that they utilize beekeeping and silk farming, anything insects, that we work on.
Silk farming also is very needed. So it's not just only food security but also income generation.
You want to improve the livelihood of people in various ways. It's not just only producing more food and that's it.
But you want all sorts of diversify their income, rather this, the risk mitigation.
So if you have a diverse income, you are not dependent on one. So you are releasing the risk also, yeah.
Speaker 1: So what would be your ultimate scientific goal?
Speaker 2: Okay, that's a big question. I think I have many goals, but I will make it a more doable one.
So I think, so tomorrow you would see these field visits in the field.
One of the critical problems in across Africa, in many countries is a parasitic weed called striga.
It is a parasite on many cereal crops, on rice, on maize, on sorghum, on millet,
all the staples that people need stable food.
And basically this is a parasitic weed, it attaches itself to the roots of it's host of the maize or sorghum
or whatever. It takes all the nutrients out from this. It cannot live without that host.
And basically it ruins the crop.
So if you have that it also produces thousands of seeds, tiny seeds, and it sheds into the soil.
So once you have that it is really. The soil is basically unusable. So we have technologies that can eradicate that.
So what I really would like to see in my lifetime is eradicating this weed from all across Africa. And it's possible.
We have the technology, what is needed is to scale it out.
To get a large number of partners and funders to say, okay, we are out to eradicate this
and then we are going to solve a major problem, food security problem for Africa.
I would like to see that within my lifetime, and I think it's doable, yeah.
Speaker 1: How important are insects for a more sustainable world?
Speaker 2: They are very important in many angles.
They are important, if you manage them well, they are important in cleaning our environment.
They are important in being the workhorse of farms. They are important as food sources.
I mean, all these chickens that are sold as organic chicken, that are free-roaming in the farm, what do they dig?
They go and dig, and they pick insects.
So you can mass-produce that and produce bigger chicken in a more sustainable way.
Fishery aquaculture, that is also, insects can play a critical role in a more sustainable production system.
Speaker 2: So I can go on and on. I think they are really important, yeah. They are important.
Speaker 1: Also in terms because you want a more sustainable Africa?
Speaker 2: Yes, absolutely, yeah.
So I think they have even more so here, because we have a myriad of diversity of insects.
As diversity of our ecological zones are big, there are varieties, there are a lot of different plants all year round.
So a lot of these insects also, they rely on plant sugar source as their thing.
Mosquitoes, so you see, many people don't know, mosquitoes, they don't just go and take my blood and they live on that.
They need specific also to sustain them, specific plant nectar as source of sugar.
Insects, more so for Africa, because of our diversity of ecology, diversity of plants, diversity of things.
We keep discovering new things.
This year alone, we discovered and published, our taxonomists and partners,
15 different new wasps which have never been described in anywhere in the world.
And some of them, they are also beneficial because they feed on harmful insects.
We have discovered, also, in Mbita, where we are going tomorrow,
one of our scientists has discovered that there is a jumping spider that is attracted only to mosquitoes that are
filled with human blood. So, and they jump and they feed on those insects.
If you give them other insects, they wouldn't touch it. They go specifically for those type of mosquitoes.
But they are, those mosquitoes,
that specific jumping spider also requires a certain plant sugar source to sustain it also between its meals of
mosquitoes, blood-filled mosquitoes. We call it vampire spider.
So what it means is also that if you keep those type of plants in your habitat,
you are going to manage also to keep equilibrium,
also that you are maintaining the spiders that feed on your mosquitoes,
that will be less mosquitoes to transmit malaria. So our world is not in black and white, it's not in boxes.
It's all a continuum.
So we have to manage it as a continuum, to make it very sustainable and very natural for the future.
So if you cause imbalance by eliminating a certain type of insects from a certain type of plants,
then you are causing an imbalance in your environment.
Speaker 1: What would be the way to go for Africa in this respect?
I mean, you have, let's say, the European agricultural system, or like the USA's doing it.
Is that the way for Africa to go for, or, you're welcome to say-
Speaker 2: Yeah, that is an excellent question, but also a complicated question. And so you can debate it either way.
You can debate it either way because, one, so for example, generally,
60% to 70% of the population in Africa is engaged in agriculture.
I don't think that is a smart way, to keep that large proportion of your population in farming.
So if you go to Europe, North America and Canada, you have about 4% or 5% of the population.
So it is very inefficient to have 70% of your population to feed the rest. So this is not efficient way to do it.
So we have to do it better. So, also, I think scientific technology alone is not going to do the trick.
So we have to have the right policy. We have to have the right environment to do these things. Why do I say policy?
Policy is important in this, because there has to be the right policy to land, and access to land, access to resources.
So if you take a,
Speaker 2: For example, many African countries, without mentioning any specific country, you have land,
the farmer has to begin with very small land. So, they have, the farmer may have six, seven children. Farmer dies.
The six, seven children split the land. So, neither one of them can make a living out of that small pieces of land.
So we have to have a policy to stop fragmenting the land to small pieces, because you cannot make a living out of it.
You cannot transform agriculture with small pieces. You cannot do a lot of different things also.
So there has to be a policy also that is favorable to,
Speaker 2: To enabling transformation of agriculture. We should be able to How this more was less.
So and we have to make our agriculture is more efficient in utilization.
And so also a large proportion of our farming system is rain fed. That's also not a sustainable way.
To wait for rain waiting in the sky for a drop of water to drop, that's not a smart way to do.
And only 4% of our land is, or the farmer land, is irrigated, and yet we have a lot of water flowing,
you have a lot of also water being wasted also.
So there's a lot of different things that we have to do to transform our farming system.
So, having said that, I don't believe that one model alone is a the model for Africa.
So it is not may not be of European model, but there are a lot of things we can borrow from, adapt from the European.
A land policy, a access to these, so our efficiency in farming, and so on.
So it's not a black and white concept I cannot give you that, yeah.
But what I know is that we can not continue keeping a large population percentage of our population in farming,
that's just not doable there, or sustainable.
Speaker 1: Can you imagine a future where insect knowledge, knowledge about insects,
will be sort of export products for Africa?
Speaker 2: Yes, actually, yes. There are a-
Speaker 1: Maybe you can repeat my question.
Speaker 2: Yeah, yeah, okay.
Speaker 1: What kind of future do insect have for-
Speaker 2: Yeah, so can Africa use insects as export product? Yes, absolutely, I believe so.
This is not actually even something for the long run, but it's already short term.
There are companies that have already exploring to establish a plant here in Africa to produce mass rare insects for
feed to Europe and somewhere else. So, yeah this is going to happen in the near future actually, yeah.
Speaker 1: Maybe you can sort of give a compressed answer on how important insects are in terms of danger.
Like what you said, there are many deaths caused by insects infectually,
many more deaths by malaria than there are any other kind of.
And there's also the beneficial things, so a little bit of compressed, kind of answer?
Speaker 2: But repeated to what I said?
Speaker 1: Yep.
Speaker 2: Okay.
Speaker 1: So if you would have to tell a nice story about what insects do mean for us, what would be your storyline?
Speaker 2: Yeah, bees are very very important for humankind. So we have to protect bees without a doubt.
So we have to make sure that they are healthy, and they live nicely, happily, and there are many ways to do that.
So, and they need to have good pollen plant source and so on.
So bees are number one, I think they are among the top which we need to do.
Natural predators, predator insects are very important, as well.
Predators that feed on harmful insects, that are harmful to people, to animals. Those are important, as well.
So, but I think we have to also pay attention and try to eradicate
or find a solution also to the myriad of major diseases that are transmitted by insects, mosquitos.
Speaker 2: That transmit malaria, that transmit dengue, that transmit also a number of other disease both in animals
and humans. Rift Valley fever and yellow fever and a number of other disease, those are important.
For Africa, Tsetse fly, Tsetse flies are really critical.
Many many fertile land in Africa has become abandoned by people because of the Tsetse fly infestation.
So these also are very important.
All of these things I have described the those are our focus for icipe, my organization, to do.
So these are some of the important things I think. We work on ticks also.
Ticks, and tick borne diseases, these are not just Africa problem, but this is a Europe, North America has a problem.
And we have products in the pipeline, that are very effective, natural products from plants,
from other microbes used in Africa.
So I think the beauty of it is Africa has a lot of these problem, insect problem that also,
a lot of also solutions also for controlling this.
So for all these problems that I have indicated, like Tsetse flies, we have a product, for example,
which came from wildlife, wild animals in Africa.
Speaker 1: Somehow, I have the feeling that your institute has a lot of hidden treasures, I don't know,
but that [CROSSTALK]
Speaker 2: Yes, we do, yeah, absolutely, yes.
Speaker 1: Can you repeat it?
Speaker 2: Yeah, and icipe, I think, has a lot of important, unique treasures that are not widely known.
But I think now also we are making a tremendous effort for the rest of the world to know what we are capable of doing,
and what we have.
So and I think also, I have to also indicate that icipe does, it also work with a lot of partners globally.
So we have more than 300 partners in Europe, North America, Asia, Latin America, and elsewhere,
including the Netherlands we have a lot of partners, so yeah.
Speaker 1: But how do you get this treasures yourself into the world?
Speaker 2: Yeah, that is a critical writing, it's critical to scale out what we have,
so that the rest of the planet can, and Africa can, make use of what we have at a faster rate.
And that is a challenge, that's a big challenge Because a research organization is a research organization,
and it's very difficult for a research organization to scale out and to reach out to a global forum, a global platform.
And so partners become very important and funding becomes important, too.
So funding, our funding, we are not a government organization,
we are international organization that happen to be based in Kenya.
So the funding comes from a lot of sources, so the European Union is among our largest investors, donors.
The governments of Germany, of Sweden, of Switzerland and UK,
many foundations they provide funding for us to make [INAUDIBLE] make a change.
So all these resources I think have to be made available, not just for Africa,
but for I think the rest of the planet as well.
Because this is also, we are using the funds of the taxpayers of Europe and North America
and so on also to generate these things, these products and find solution for constraints.
Speaker 1: A totally other question, if you would have to describe your philosophy of life, what would it be?
What do you look for yourself and humanity and the future?
Speaker 2: Yeah, philosophy of life, I think for me, my motto personality is, and I tell my daughter also.
I have one daughter, who is going to be a scientist also, she just joined a university in America, first year.
So, my motto is live life with a purpose, not just for yourself,
but really to contribute to changing lives for those people who are less fortunate than we are.
And I think there are millions of people who don't have the skills or the resources that we have.
So it will be a tragedy for any humankind to live for himself or herself.
Like, if I have a good life myself, yeah the rest is like, okay.
So I think we have to, if we see suffering of a fellow human being, we have to suffer together.
We have to feel their pain. So, and I think if we have the mindset and the skills, we should do it.
We should make use of it, yeah, certainly, yeah.
Speaker 1: And can you say that science is changing,
because our knowledge is spreading out quicker than ever around the planet, you see that?
Speaker 2: Yeah, yeah, whether science is making a difference to the planet at a pace that we want,
that is questionable, I don't have yes or no answer.
However, I know that our lives have tremendously changed because of contributions of science.
If you just back several decades back before the invention of antibiotics,
before we had access to the first antibiotic, penicillin, which was accidentally discovered from a mold from a fungus.
Speaker 2: Before that people were dying from very simple treatable things, from an infection.
Speaker 2: So that's not the case any more.
And then since the discovery of penicillin a lot of range of antibiotics were discovered from microbes, from plants,
from other sources. So yes, science has made a tremendous difference for us.
The vaccines, Polio is almost eradicated, so here and there only.
Vaccines, people were dying from a lot of preventive disease, but the tragedy of it is even to this day,
Speaker 2: Preventable diseases are still killing people in the developing world today.
People are dying from infection, because they don't have access to simple antibiotics.
Or they didn't have the means or the knowledge that [INAUDIBLE]
if they vaccinate the kids at a certain age that they will prevent [INAUDIBLE] diseases.
To this day, myself, I don't know what I have been vaccinated. I don't think I have been vaccinated when I was a kid.
This is the world we live, the haves and the have-nots, and the gaps, so big difference, yeah?
But, yes, science has made a tremendous, tremendous difference in our lives, yeah.
And I think it will continue doing it, but I think governments have to value science.
Not only in Africa, but globally, and do significant investment or so in science and technologies, so yeah.